[Music]
step right up and behold one of the
unexplained mysteries of the universe is
he man or beast
[Music]
this preacher
has been examined by the former
scientists and pronounced unequivocally
a man
i am prepared to offer you folks
one last chance
to witness the supreme oddity
where did it come from
forgotten by the same lost and threat
that got us all walking on this earth
but gone wrong somehow in maternal wombs
is it a beast
or is it a man
you're in luck because tonight you will
see him feed
come on in and find out
is he man or beast
wanted to see me sir sound girl thank
you coach i prefer to stand
all right go ahead then
tell me
tell you what
why a team worth 800 million dollars one
of the most complex offenses ever built
should put you in the driver's seat
you're too old to be working too green
to be a pro
[Music]
so why in the world would i give you
this shot
[Music]
all my life
i've defined myself through sports
i've always come up empty
coach i can win for you you need to
start thinking about life after football
son
we gave you the chance
we're letting you go
i was meant for something
something more
you think you could be that guy
yeah i do
what are you doing here
i wasn't ready for it
but i am now
you've decided
i've waited for it
i bled for it
i know who i am
i know why i'm here
if you give me a chance green went down
hard and is not getting up
i will not let you down
[Music]
something special about you son
that's simply
belongs to the underdogs
you want to prove that
[Music]
hey what are you guys doing out here
it's halloween we've been
trick-or-treating are you alone there's
a creepy man in a white mask
where
and he keeps like trying to play hide
and seek with us where did you see him
run go now
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
we killed michael
my grandmother set the fire
no one told you
tell me what michael myers is alive
a man couldn't have survived that fire
40 years ago the boogeyman came for us
we are the survivors of michael myers
what do we do we fight
mom we're family we'll kill him we're
gonna hunt him down and we're gonna put
an end to this
he is not gonna stop killing until we
stop him
if you track michael's victims that's a
straight line
to michael's childhood home
someone's in our house
coming for me
but i'm coming for him
you want to kill someone take me michael
i want to take his mask off and see the
life of leave his eyes
it all happened so fast
there was a solar flare
goodbye crops and food goodbye
everything
[Music]
so i did
[Music]
frighten
and so alone
and i found you
[Music]
where should we have
get your elbows off the table keep your
elbows up
all right you're next
you see i'm developing something
interesting
giant leap of faith
now if you can speak
tell me something
about you robots must protect dog
if we don't go before that storm hits
we'll die all of us
as soon as you can walk we're leaving
[Music]
head west over the mountains would you
like me to drive
don't over steer
that's over here
use your foot up just a hair
perfect
[Music]
i don't think it likes me
come and see this
hang on to
[Music]
something we should be safe once we get
into the mountains those things will
happen
like 150 degree heat
uv radiation
and people
hiding in the shadows
do you think we'll make it
not without my team
what we do
we do together
i believe in you things
[Music]
foreign
jesus
foreign
[Music]
london college of fashion
is on the top floor it's perfect i love
it
i can live any place in any time i live
here in london
in the 60s
last night i saw something in my dreams
[Music]
there was a girl
and you are sandy
[Music]
i got this kind of gift
i can see people faces
things are this kind
this is the closest most people ever get
to their dreams
[Music]
[Music]
jack i don't want to do this you think
you can just walk away
it really happened
what did you see
[Music]
do you believe in ghosts
[Applause]
you witnessed the murder last night but
you believe this was a vision from the
past
the guy that killed her is to like that
i have to stop him
where are you going
i know what you did i've done a lot of
things
you can have to be more specific love
you can't save me
pharmacy truck got hit the other night
on its way to okc
i'm gonna need you hop out and open up
the back
whoever it was knew exactly what they
were looking for
stop looking at me be cool be
cool so why do you do it
what's in our blood
hey sweet boy
how'd it go
yeah that's what i heard
hey happy birthday buddy thank you have
you met lawrence yet nice to meet you
out of walker doing 25 for murder and
conspiracy
anything major went down her name always
came up
so what's your wife think of this she
knows who she married i think they
really understand how far her reach goes
she wants us clean it up
i'll do it
who's there
alex and wyatt
what sent you i had a red
follow me
how much is this job
10 baby
every mother grouper oh man flies in
from the middle east
they bring back cash deals they don't
report
and we do this we're done that's it
i see that look in your eye like you're
up to something i know what she turned
you into
there
strap up
you might have to make some difficult
choices
tonight
the world is full
of life
[Music]
this is my first time in new york city
i want to be happy here i want to make a
life at home
[Music]
are you ready
tonight is about family
the first gringo boy who smiles at you
i never seen you before
you're not puerto rican
is that okay
do you want to start world war three
[Applause]
you know i wake up to everything i know
either getting sold or wrecked or being
taken over by people that i don't like
you keep away from him as long as you're
in my house
i'm a grown-up now bernardo i'm gonna
think for myself
tony
we need you if we're going to work
who are you
wonderful
if you go with him
no one will ever forgive you
[Applause]
[Music]
life matters
even more than love
[Music]
this one started out just like the last
one so excited about tonight what you
got going till then gotta go see my mom
i'm better i've been better for months
maybe you could just come home then
ain't that easy baby girl
we didn't know it yet
hey chris
do i know you but this summer
[Music]
hey leave him alone
was about to be very different
if i tell you what i have to tell you
you have to promise to believe me no
matter what
oh what is science i got attacked oh my
god are you up by a group of homeless
vampires
[ __ ]
i didn't know who was responsible but i
was going to make him pay
there's fire and decapitation got your
house back
maybe we should just go i think we use a
wooden stake what
they're vampires duh
i had a plan
revenge
look deep into my eyes
do you know where you are
i can't remember
go
go
home
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
isn't that why we formed the justice
league to do what's right
protecting the monsters look who you're
standing with
everyone has to make their own choice
about this oh so now he's god from what
i've heard most of the magical heroes
feel the same way superman you've had an
unfathomable loss you need time to
process it
let yourself fall apart
you took his wife
you took his unborn child
why after all these years bassey you
really need reasons from me
now that's
a french line
what happened to metropolis can never be
allowed to occur again
i won't be held back by ideals that
don't protect the innocent
you'll throw away everything the justice
league stands for
you're his best friend talk to him
superman has created a police state he
needs to be stopped the laws of superman
will not be the laws of atlantis this
time the jokes on you
i thought i could redeem you
i was wrong
so
by the pricking of my thumbs
something wicked
this way comes
[Music]
is she here yet
not yet mom no
then she's late
yes
she is late
[Music]
you're our highness
mommy
family are all gathered in the drawing
room
they are waiting
[Music]
three days
that's it
they're getting quite serious about you
so stand very still and smile a lot
they know everything
they don't
mommy what happened to make you so sad
well here
is there is no future past and the
present to the same thing
diana
they can't change you have to change
you have to be able to do things you
hate you hate there has to be two of you
it's the real one
and the one thing take
for the good of the country
[Music]
there's
[Music]
[Music]
will they kill me if you think
[Music]
have a seat mr mickelson
where would you like to go
you can be anytime you care
[Music]
too love is drawn in the form of a
circle of forever
always
in all ways
the past doesn't just belong to old
photos and history books anymore now we
can live it
touch it
change it
[Music]
wherever you are
whatever you are
i will find you
we'll find our way back
what if you go back and change your past
but you end up with no future
i'm starting to forget my wife
[Music]
don't regret the past
that's what brings us to where we need
to be
we're all set have a wonderful trip
five
four
three
two
let's see what the past has waiting for
you
[Music]
are you an illustrator
yes
you're very muddy i was attacked by one
and a half ton bull oh
i'm prepared to offer you a staff
position you capture something of a cat
perhaps because you yourself are an
outcast
i do to provide for the five hungry and
precocious sisters that i live at home
with
and we've had a governess i think you're
the first person to see the cats are
ridiculous
frightened
and brave
like
us miss richardson has had an incredibly
positive effect on this family were you
painting something
is something funny miss wayne not at all
[Music]
did you say that they would turn blue
yes of course wow
what's going on in that funny little
head of yours
[Music]
electricity
okay louie i'm worried about you
i feel
electricity
[Music]
mr wayne i have been called here because
your sister is concerned for your health
you have squandered it on wretched cats
and on a willful doomed tainted romance
how you've managed
to conjure images of such delight
at such a dark time
i don't know
just remember
[Music]
i have hard things get
how much you feel like you're struggling
the world is full of beauty
and it's up to you to capture it only
and to share it with as many people as
you can
[Music]
[Music]
dear evan hansen is a musical love
letter to all those who feel alone have
you been doing those letters to yourself
with dr sherman i've been trying to dear
evan hansen
today is going to be an amazing day
and here's why
[Music]
because today all you have to do is just
be yourself
[Music]
but also confident that's that's
important and interesting easy to talk
to approachable but mostly just be
yourself you know that's number one
obviously be yourself but like a
confident version of yourself
i've learned to slam on the break
before i even turn the key
before i make the mistake
before i lead with the worst of me
give them no reason it's there
no slipping up if you slip away so i got
nothing to share
no i got nothing to say
would you want to sign my cast because
we're friends we're family friends evan
would anyone even notice if i just
disappear tomorrow
sincerely our best and most dearest
friend me um no one's on your cast
now we can both pretend we have friends
uh dear evan hansen
yeah yeah that's mine i'll i'll just
take it wait i really i need that back
please don't show it to anyone on the
outside always looking in will i ever be
more than i've always been cause i'm tap
tap tapping on the glass
i'm waiting through a window
i
try to speak upon
[Music]
connor took a letter from me and it was
an assignment for my therapist still
connor murphy's mother and stepfather
here to see connor wanted you to have
this
dear evan hansen he wrote it to you his
last words conor took his own life
i'm sorry connor didn't write this no no
please we didn't think connor had any
friends
[Music]
am you really going to tell these people
that the only thing they have left of
their son is a letter that you wrote to
yourself so you and connor tell us
something please have him right um i
started talking and you couldn't stop
they didn't want me to stop i'm putting
together memorial service if you wanted
to do something
in the forest and there's nobody around
connie showed me that that i wasn't
alone nobody is i wish we could have
given that to you
[Music]
people started sharing it it's
everywhere i don't understand what
happened
it's like i never made a sound will i
ever make a sound
a lot of people feel like us people that
you wouldn't think you don't know how
much you've given my family and me
i never thought that it would go this
far i was trying to help
watching people pass
you know who i am can anybody see just
the health broken land i already know
you and i love you
i have to tell them
[Music]
just because you were number one once
does not mean you will be again i will
be number one
who are you i'm kate
i'm here to win the prize
they pick one girl and one boy for the
contract for the paris opera ballet
[Music]
she's testing you
she's torturing me too
anyone who partners with lee bae will be
the better dancer he's the key to the
prize
maybe you could help me
do you always follow the rules
no
prove it
my heart is on fire i'm gonna catch
three and we're gonna both stop why
should i trust you
one
two
three
[Music]
this is our secret
[Music]
you win or not
i'm in
[Music]
we're not gonna let anything or anyone
come between us
[Music]
what kind of game are you trying to play
you made me think you're actually
friends i would never purposefully hurt
you
it's always been about sex
blood
money
it's all that matters
[Music]
greatness has a price
do you agree
[Music]
oh
[Music]